[Musique]
nicolas mainville bonjour je vous en
prie installez vous pour votre café
politique toujours options à montigny le
bretonneux nous allons parler de votre
parcours de vos engagements aussi puis
un peu d'actualité
vous êtes conseiller départemental du
canton de trappes depuis peu vous avez
pris la place de jean michel fourgous
maire d'elancourt est maintenant
président de saint quentin en yvelines
vous étiez son suppléant il a quitté le
département vous avez pris à sa place et
puis 2002 puis 2014
vous êtes aussi conseiller municipal
d'opposition à la verrière et vous
n'avez qu'une trentaine d'années
comment vous êtes arrivé en politique ça
comme elle commence je suis un peu comme
obélix même 16 voit pas physiquement je
faisais bettencourt était petit jet
d'une famille qui était passionné par
les débats par l'histoire de france et
mon père collectionner les anciennes
affiches qui décollait sauvagement jeu
très bien sucrés du coup j'ai grandi
dans dans cette ambiance très politique
et puis j'ai connu des premiers
engagements notamment sur le thème de la
famille car g qui me tient beaucoup à
coeur et avec tout le mouvement de la
manif pour tous je m'étais vraiment
beaucoup impliqué pour défendre un
modèle familial qui me semblait le plus
à même de garantir
voilà le le le
le droit des enfants vous avez milité
très jeune avec une orientation
politique clair dès le début c'était
plutôt votre famille aujourd'hui c'est
l'est républicain plutôt une famille de
droite
effectivement j'ai toujours été attiré
par l'esprit d'initiative par
l'entrepreneuriat par l'esprit
d'innovation par l'amour de la france
parle envie de servir mon pays je me
suis aussi engagé dans la marine
nationale
une certaine période de ma vie et donc
effectivement ça me classe plutôt à
droite de l'échiquier politique
mais j'ai surtout envie de rassembler
notamment à la verrière donc voilà des
cartes aujourd'hui aux républicains
alors j'ai eu ma carte républicains ils
voient que je renouvelle pour la
caravane ayew mais effectivement je me
sens plutôt à droite sur l'échiquier
politique essentiellement sur les thèmes
économiques et puis sur les thèmes
plutôt sociétaux on va parler de tout ça
on va revenir à la politique de petites
une petite parenthèse sur ce que vous
venez de dire vous avez fait cette
préparation militaire supérieure avant
de devenir officier de réserve dans la
marine nationale
qu'est ce qui vous a motivé là aussi et
puis pourquoi ne pas avoir aussi
continuer dans cette branche là alors ce
qui m'a motivé c'est l' envie de servir
mon pays il envie de servir concrètement
l'envi de consacrer du temps dans
l'armée c'est une formation
extraordinaire g7 où les jeunes à la
suivre c'est une formation de
réservistes il ya une formation pour
ceux qui sont en dessous de bac + 3
d'autres qui sont destinés pour ceux qui
ont une licence une formation on
embarque d'ailleurs à bord d'un bâtiment
de la marine nationale pour une petite
période j'étais sur le siroco au large
de toulon période extraordinaire où on
apprend l'esprit de camaraderie on
apprend la rigueur le respect de
l'autorité
tout ça vous sert aujourd'hui et tout ça
me sert aujourd'hui parce que c'est des
valeurs qui nous marque et qui sont
importantes je pense à transmettre aux
jeunes et j'ai regretté mois l'absence
d'un service militaire je pensais que
c'était une bonne manière aussi de
passer du temps
collectivement de brasser aussi les
milieux sociaux et puis
de passer du temps pour pour la france
et donc c'est pour ça que j'ai fait à
cette formation
j'ai pas pu là je veux plus continuer
dans l'armée parce que je n'étais pas
fait pour ça et c'est une voilà une
formation de réservistes qui me
correspond parfaitement pour faire
rayonner aussi la marine nationale dans
mon métier et dans ma vie active et
diplômé d hec de sciences po domaine de
prédilection vous en avait parlé tout à
l'heure emploi développement économique
à la marche de la de la famille aussi on
l'a entendu puisque le gouvernement
propose aujourd'hui en matière
économique de développement économique
des deux entreprises
est-ce que ça va dans le bon sens selon
vous écoutez ça va dans le bon sens
c'est un programme économique qui est
bien plus rassurant que celui par
exemple pro macron alors finalement d'un
point de vue économique il ya des très
bonnes mesures je pense
aux mesures sur le marché du travail je
pense aux mesures à venir sur
l'apprentissage
je pense que c'est une bonne orientation
après il ya des mesures mac imac est
séparant serait taxe d'habitation qui va
rendre les communes totalement
dépendante de l'état avec des budgets
qui seront dépendants plus de 60 % pour
certaines villes je pense que c'est une
mesure typique qui électoraliste qui a
permis à emmanuel macron de faire un bon
coup de com mais qui met beaucoup de
communes dans des situations vraiment
très très compliqué et donc voilà je
suis pas du tout ma chronique je ne sais
pas en marche
économiquement il ya des bonnes choses
et donc il faut le saluer mais sur
d'autres aspects je suis vraiment nos
positions sur 100 sans lien au
territoire sont bien aux communes c'est
vrai que beaucoup de députés ont
débarqué du jour au lendemain sans avoir
un lien au territoire qui me semble
important savoir une expérience concrète
des territoires dans lesquels ils se
sont implantés donc ça ça m'a vraiment
gêné et puis surtout les thèmes
sociétaux
je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de naïveté
naïveté sur sur l'immigration naïveté
sur un certain nombre de sujets qui
concernent la famille on en a parlé avec
la pma avec la gpa les mères porteuses
donc sur ces thèmes là je suis en
réserve en opposition mais il faut
saluer aussi les bonnes choses donc
voilà je pense d'une démarche
constructive et au sein des républicains
alors vous n'avez pas encore renouveler
votre carte est ce que vous allez le
faire ou pas est ce que le choix de
laurent wauquiez vous l'approuvez par
exemple parce qu'il ya des sceptiques
qui on pourrait parler de valérie
pécresse par exemple j'ai eu des départs
aussi un de certains ténors de la pub
lique 1 vous positionnez-vous alors moi
déjà je suis très démocrate il ya une
élection il a été élu
avec un score sans conteste donc c'est
le président des républicains
je pense que c'est un homme brillant
intellectuellement
il a été formé à bonne école il a aussi
ce sens du territoire dont on parlait
précédemment
donc moi je ne suis pas de ceux qui
critiquent laurent wauquiez attendons de
voir ses propositions attendons de voir
la manière dont il gère le parti
vous parlez de valérie pécresse je
trouve que aussi son initiative va dans
le bon sens à oxygène aussi à la droite
on a besoin de rassembler et donc je
pense que c'est ça qui garantira la
reconquête avenir que je souhaite donc
il va falloir reconstruire aussi et si
on s'écarte du national pour se
concentrer sur le département et blinois
là aussi pour les républicains il ya du
travail aujourd'hui à david douillet est
toujours le président président qui a
pris un peu de recul de retrait c'est
plutôt sophie primas qui gère
aujourd'hui la fédération la sénatrice
[Musique]
aujourd'hui pour les républicains dans
dans les yvelines quel est le style et
la personnalité peut-être qui pourrait
incarner cette reconstruction
on entend parler des fois du nom de
pierre bédier aussi pour prendre la tête
des républicains
écoutez je pense qu'il faudra surtout
être collectif il faudra vraiment qu'on
rassemble qu'on rassemble toutes les
sensibilités
qu'on se mette au travail de d'avoir des
actions concrètes des actions concrètes
saissac attend d'eux les militants et
puis de reconquérir le coeur et la
raison aussi de ceux qui ont pu quitter
le giron de la droite républicaine donc
c'est un travail de fond et avec des
idées fortes des idées qui se démarque
aussi évidemment je pense que c'est une
erreur de de se caler sur emmanuel
macron je pense que il faut saluer les
bonnes mesures mais il faut défendre
aussi notre ligne je pense que sur
l'immigration il faut être être plus
ferme parce qu'on a on a dépassé le
seuil d'acceptabilité pour un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens on a un modèle
social qui doit être réformé qui peut
imploser
si on ne fait rien et je pense que on a
un niveau d'acceptation qui est en train
d'être dépassé donc voilà faut plus de
fermeté sur le droit d'asile
on a 95 % par exemple des déboutés du
droit d'asile qui reste illégalement sur
le sol national c'est un vrai problème
puisque la loi n'est plus respectée donc
il faut je pense des mesures fortes
ferme
et puis si on au territoire je pense à
la verrières ont enfin j'allais y venir
il ya beaucoup de maires de droite qui
qui qui font des mesures extraordinaires
dans leur ville qui innove sur le
numérique sur la manière de gérer les
ressources humaines dans leur commune
jeu pour sa karl olive à poissy et donc
d'aider des jeunes des jeunes mères une
jeune génération qui s'emparent de leur
mairie de leur territoire pour faire des
choses très concrètes avec des valeurs
de centre droite et je pense que c'est
la voie à suivre pour reconstruire dans
les yvelines
notre famille politique sachant que karl
olive lui a fait le choix de pas
forcément renouveler sa carte aux
républicains était passé pour le recul
c'est son droit
je pense qu'il faut rester soudés en ce
moment deux tempêtes et avec des idées
donc là on en parlait des idées qui
peuvent aller à l'encontre de ce qui est
aussi attendu bousculer un petit peu ça
vous savez faire vous l'avez fait sur la
verrière
lorsqu'on est un élu en tout cas un
représentant de la droite c'est pas
forcément évident théoriquement
communiste vous aviez obtenu 40% des
suffrages est néanmoins en 2014 c'était
un score historique face à un élu un élu
communiste sortant dans cette ville qui
est détenu depuis très longtemps par
l'extrême gauche sur le terrain
aujourd'hui ses idées la porte encore
comment comment vous travaillez son
terrain de la verrière et avec quelle
idée on a parlé de la famille notamment
tout à l'heure écoutez je pense que les
verts y est roi comme un certain nombre
d'habitants étaient contents d'avoir un
élu ou un candidat qui proposait des
choses différentes
c'est vrai que depuis quarante ans vous
l'avais dit la verrière est une ville
communiste avec les mêmes méthodes avec
ça par contre je n'ai pas dit je vous
laisse le dire j'ai dit que c'était une
ville communiste les mêmes méthodes de
gestion ont des liens avec la la même
idéologie avec les mêmes pratiques
politiques et je pense que on a besoin
de changer on a vu avec elle en cours et
l'encours était une ville aussi
historiquement à gauche pendant très
longtemps et avec jean michel fourgous
ya eu des nouvelles méthodes concrètes
sur le terrain on l'a vu à l'école avec
une nouvelle méthode pédagogique pour
plus d'égalité des chances avec du
soutien scolaire en ligne gratuit avec
un curseur placé sur la réussite sur
l'ascension sociale plutôt que des
discours de défiance plutôt que des
discours de victimisation d'apitoiement
c'était un discours pour essayer de
redonner confiance aux jeunes de
redonner confiance aux familles de les
aider bien évidemment quand elles sont
dans le besoin et il faut vraiment ne
pas les laisser tomber
mais aussi leur donner de l'espoir leur
donner de l'ambition les sortir aussi
d'un certain nombre de quartiers qui
sont dits sensibles pour leur faire voir
autre chose mettre en avant les valeurs
mais les réussites des quartiers je
pense que c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
beaucoup d'avant faire davantage mettre
en avant ceux qui ont réussi pour donner
envie aux plus jeunes aussi de s'élever
de réussir et leur donner de l'ambition
ça c'est vraiment les mesures que j'ai
envie de
de proposer et donc vous serez candidat
à un nouveau mandat je l'espère je
l'espère avec toute mon équipe en tout
cas vous rester implanté sur la mairie
me lâche rien je reste plus que tout
implanté sur la verrière et sur
l'ensemble du canton et on essaye de se
battre au quotidien pour proposer des
mesures innovantes et puisse inspirer de
ce qui marche dans nos communes voisines
on parle d'elancourt on a parlé de
poissy il ya beaucoup d'initiatives
concrètes sur l'éducation sur la
sécurité notamment à aulnay sous bois
avec bruno beschizza avec une police
municipale le plus forte une police de
proximité avec une peau lisse parfois
qui armée une police qui a des caméras
pour rétablir un certain lien de
confiance avec la population plein
d'initiatives que j'ai envie d'évoquer
que j'ai envie de mettre sur la place
publique pour aborder puis essaie de
faire bouger les choses
est ce que vous êtes dans une optique de
deux carrières politiques vous pensez
aussi à la députation par exemple ce
genre de choses là
non chaque chose
en son temps là fut très heureux d'être
conseiller départemental j'ai envie de
faire des belles choses je pense un
projet d'une tient à coeur c'est
d'ouvrir une école de la fondation
expérience banlieue une école qui a déjà
ouvertes sartrouville à asnières à
montfermeil qui sont des écoles hors
contrat qui essaye de répondre aux vrais
besoins d'un certain nombre d'habitants
dans ces quartiers difficiles ou
sensibles avec un uniforme qui renforce
le sentiment d'appartenance dans l'école
qui cible c'est vraiment sur les la
transmission des fondamentaux qui
redonne confiance aux jeunes qu'ils
essayent de les sortir aussi de leur
quartier je pense que si on arrive en
tant que conseiller départemental à
ouvrir une école de ce type à trappes ou
la verrière on peut faire de belles
choses moi c'est plutôt ça qui m'anime
c'est d'avoir un bilan concret et ce
genre d'école ont fait partie on va
arriver à la fin de cet entretien
dernière question bien loin de là de la
politique la france a perdu une nouvelle
icône musicale récemment avec la
disparition de france gall et une
chanson particulière que vous retiendrez
a coûté basse et résiste mieux que tu
existes qui est vraiment une force
extraordinaire et puis je citerai quand
même génial idée qui m'a beaucoup marqué
qu'à être une icône une idole des jeunes
qui est devenu une icône d'un pays et
qui a réussi à brasser beaucoup de
milieux beaucoup de générations jusqu'à
son concert au stade de france
il ya quelques années qui m'a beaucoup
marqué et donc
vraiment des icônes qui me marque je
sais trop si michel berger puisse
comparer de france gall donc vraiment
des icônes populaires
donc ils nous font du bien dans ces
temps parfois trop nombreuses
merci nicolas adam ville élue à la
verrière et au conseil départemental des
yvelines d'avoir participé à ce café
colis merci à vous merci où les fans
[Musique]